well with now is the United States
ambassador to the court of Sir James he
is of course the American investigate
Matthew balls and welcome to you First
Lady we know has a long-standing
interest in education in girls education
but clearly this decision to go to tower
hamlets to a majority Muslim school was
appointed one it was rip I mean I think
the report just there showed how
powerful it was for those girls and you
could hear how it meant it was very
powerful for the first lady herself and
you could see her reacting so the energy
in that room certainly flowed in both
directions and look I mean she could
have picked there are lots of other
wonderful surrounding around the UK but
wasn't one web less the girls we're sure
and I think she explained you know a
reason for that but I think the point
that she was trying to make in the
address is one that applies to all girls
in the United Kingdom hand back home in
the United States which is they're all
doing well they're excelling they're
studying hard and she's urging them to
keep doing that but also to connect with
other girls around the world especially
the 62 million think about that almost
the population of the UK 62 million
girls who do not go to school that was
the focus as the American are you
surprised by the radicalization within
the British Muslim community it's
something we struggle with in the United
States the UK is struggling with other
countries in Europe are struggling with
and we need to and we are working
together to figure out ways to deal with
it and it's not there's no one simple
answer but what I think you saw today
with the first lady is certainly a part
of it and she asked them to join you
know she's saying let girls learn join
in the effort to reach back to the
communities where you may have come from
or other places you may never have been
to reach those girls and encourage them
and do your part because but that is as
it is a clash of values isn't it because
you know we know in Pakistan that just
for going to school Malala was you know
someone tried to murder her and other
people have been murdered and there is
clearly divergent values well and it's
something in the case of Malala it's
something that the first lady mentioned
remarks that weren't part of that report
the other thing the first lady went on
to say is applauding the UK for its
leadership around the world and think
about what did and other organizations
are doing in Pakistan to pick that
particular place not limited to Pakistan
other places in sub-saharan Africa doing
the hard work to remove those barriers
for these girls to get them into school
because if you can remove those barriers
all the research shows that it improves
the economy it improves public health
that improve security oh and by the way
it's the right thing to do is that what
the UK is therefore if you like the soft
/ doing doing the right thing
representing values rather than as a
military ally for example that's both
hands up some criticism of Britain's
failure to honor it may take and then to
value the UK is leading around the world
with all the tools that it has just like
the United States is leading around the
world with all the tools it has look how
the UK in the u.s. stood up together to
deal with the Ebola threat in West
Africa far from both our shores but
living up to the values that we share so
that's a good example we're doing more
you know military things together but
Iraq and doing things like today to
address girls education especially
adolescent girls education and those
things of course connect to security
prosperity so if we take amidst all the
warm remarks some of the mornings we've
had from the president down about
Britain's military spending about
Britain's relationship with Europe he's
America worried that Britain is a
country and decline as a global power UK
is a global power you see it every
single day around the world we have no
closer partner than the UK for the you
know look at what we're doing together
as I mentioned with ISIL trying to
defeat it not just the ILA Terry angle
stop the flow yeah but you know that you
know there's more criticism in this
country of the recent military
involvement in Iraq and Afghanistan
there is as I say this declining
to expenditure below the levels that are
recommended and there is a lot of common
one can read it from politicians Andy
from welcome you and then the two
percent we've always said it the fact is
Britain is one of the only I think only
four countries including the United
States UK estonia in greece i think who
hit the two percent target now we think
that's really important and we think
lots of other things are important too I
mean the other thing including things
like the work that if it is doing around
the world are equivalent of diff it is
USAID the Peace Corps on our side how
can we use all the tools we have and do
it in effect but the other thing that
struck me was it's a 800th anniversary
celebration of Magna Carta and Americans
evil was to care about it more than more
than we do I mean awful you built the
monument and put the monument to
Jonathan Kennedy there we have a huge
debt to Magna Carta we are inspired by
it in our history you know we brought it
over the first settlers and then we were
inspired by it when we declared our
independence from this country and then
we've used it I think the important
thing to focus on you saw that it on
Monday with the runnymede celebrations
when our attorney general Loretta Lynch
came over expressly for that so the
highest law enforcement officer in the
land coming to the UK to thank the UK
for the inheritance of the Magna Carta
and the fact is yes the history is
really interesting but you know what
this is working right now today as we
try to to pick one example fight
corruption around the world so the rule
of law and the relevance of the rule of
law is absolutely relevant today you see
that with the US and the UK
shoulder-to-shoulder to pick one example
sticking up to help the people of
Ukraine and to impose consequences on
costs and consequences on Russia for
their aggression and violation of
territory and haven't you mentioned
Eastern Europe that would do UK still be
as relevant if it votes to come out the
European Union our position on this one
has been clear which is it's entirely up
to the Brits on how they deal with their
lives within within Europe no but forgot
hey look if you ask us of course it's up
to you and of course we care why
wouldn't we care we value our strong
partner
with you you'd like to say the UK makes
every organization it's a part of
stronger we know that from once where we
sit literally next to each other because
of an accident of alphabet United States
United Kingdom but we stand next to each
other not by accident because we share
these same values UN Security Council
NATO OSCE OECD all these organizations
benefit from UK's global outlook and
their global commitment and that's what
you saw today and that's what the first
lady was my guide lighting a you as well
he America caught offices so we do we
value a strong UK and the strong are you
okay thank you st thank you